from major retailers to luxury stores
and small businesses organized retail
crime also known as orc has been on the
rise for several years with a spike in
incidents over the last few weeks
orc incidents involve any form of retail
theft by an organized group from
shoplifting to cargo theft
recently there has been a spike in smash
and grab organized retail crime where
large groups smash display windows and
can steal thousands of dollars in
merchandise within minutes
i probably saw 50 to 80 people in like
ski mass crowbars night like a bunch of
weapons they were looting the nordstrom
right here nearly three-fourths of us
retailers said they saw a spike in orc
in 2020 according to a national retail
security survey and many said the
pandemic has played a role as covid
influenced the way america shops
everybody was buying their goods online
so it created this incredible increase
in demand for online products organized
until crime organizations stepped up to
fill that demand
ben dugan has been following trends in
retail crime for 30 years and has worked
with cvs for the last four years to
investigate orc incidents
he says members of orc groups can target
as many as 15 to 20 stores in a single
day and often resell the stolen goods as
a third-party seller on various online
marketplaces well the biggest challenge
when dealing with illicit sellers on
online marketplaces first and foremost
is who they are they do not have to
provide their real names or addresses or
banking information or information that
that any legitimate business
would provide as cvs health's top
investigator dugan said he solved 27
cases of e-commerce crime in 2020 alone
amounting to nearly 50 million dollars
worth of goods earlier this year a
bipartisan group of senators introduced
the inform consumers act which would
require e-commerce platforms to verify
high-volume third-party seller
information
ultimately making it more difficult to
sell stolen goods from locking up
products and ramping up physical
security measures to installing gps
tracking on products stores are finding
new ways to combat potential orc
incidents specifically smash and grab
robberies
our retailers are doing a lot
especially this holiday season as always
the number one concern for the retail
community and industry is to keep our
employees and our customers safe
[Music]